Here's the greatest hack you've probably
never heard about doing market research.
Be the market. Reverse engineer your own
buying habits for the things that you
want to sell. For instance, I love
running, which makes it so easy for me
to write emails and ads and things like
that for runners selling running shoes,
running jackets, whatever, because I am
the target market, so I understand my
pains, my [music] desires, my obstacles,
and all of those things are already in
my brain, which makes it so much easier
to translate it onto paper. So, if you
want to write copy faster, easier, and
sell more, write for the market that you
are in.